[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the very
first video for Harry Potter theory I
have been a massive Harry Potter fan all
my life I read the books when I was a
kid like crazy just like everyone else
and I watched all the movies so I felt
it was fitting to make a Harry Potter
theory channel now I will be doing
something a little bit different on this
channel I want you all to welcome my
very very good friend Silas
now Silas actually funny enough has an
English accent he's from the UK and
we've been best friends for years now so
we're growths gonna be doing this
channel he is a massive Harry Potter fan
if anything he knows more about it than
I do so with his help we're gonna be
running this channel and I can't wait
for it I'm really excited for it so
today's video is going to basically kick
things off by covering a topic that I'm
sure everyone has asked themselves at
some point which ones are the most
powerful in the Harry Potter universe in
this video we're gonna cover the top
five most powerful ones hey everyone
this is Silas and I'm going to be
starting off the list for you now coming
in at number five on the list is the
wand of Bellatrix Lestrange wielded by
the infamous Death Eater herself the
first one of Bellatrix Lestrange was
constructed by Garrick Ollivander of
Ollivanders in Diagon Alley it was 12
and three-quarter inches long and made
of walnut with a dragon heartstring core
described by Ollivander as unyielding it
was the cause of much pain and suffering
to many the list of people who suffered
at the hands of this wand includes
serious black Nymphadora Dobby Neville
Longbottom parents and many more the
ones specialty was causing pain which
paired well with Bellatrix's affinity
for the Cruciatus curse in Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows hermione finds
herself in possession of this wand
shortly before impersonating Bellatrix
Lestrange however she found the one to
be extremely sinister and entirely
distasteful to wield coming in at number
four on the list
is the wonderful character you might
know you guessed it Harry Potter himself
now
Harry's one is 11 inches long made of
Holly and is one of two ones that
contain a phoenix feather core the only
other one in existence that contained
this core was the brother to Harry's
wand and it long - well we'll get to
that later the power of Harry's wand is
exhibited in numerous instances most
notably when Harry was able to produce
an imperious curse a Patronus and a
shield charm all while still being a
very young wizard number 3 the wand of
Lord Voldemort you just saw Harry's wand
so you're probably not surprised that
the brother to Harry's wand possessed by
Lord Voldemort comes in at number 3 on
this list voldemort's wand was 13 and a
half inches long and was made of you
with a phoenix feather core voldemort's
wand is arguably one of the most
infamous destructive ones in the entire
area Potter universe and was responsible
for the famous scar on Aerys forehead
voldemort's wand specialty was perfectly
paired with Voldemort signature spell
Avada Kedavra
its capabilities did not stop at a bada
Kedavra and has been showcased as being
able to achieve a variety of feats
including conjuring a fire serpent and
producing Horcruxes the list of people
who fell victim to this dark wand is
enormous but most notably it was
responsible for the deaths of Lily and
James Potter number 2
Dumbledore's original wand the double
door that we know and love didn't always
possess the Elder Wand and there was a
time when just like every other witch
and wizard
Dumbledore went out and bought his very
own first wand it is speculated that
Dumbledore purchased this wand in 1892
right after he turned 11 years old it's
likely that he purchased the wand from
Gare bald Ollivander the grandfather of
Garrick Ollivander why is this one so
powerful you might ask well it was with
this wand that Dumbledore was able to
defeat Grindelwald who was in possession
of the Elder Wand
this brings me to my next one number one
the Elder Wand
the most powerful wand in the Harry
Potter universe is undeniably the Elder
Wand wielded by Dumbledore from 1945
onwards it is the source of great power
perhaps the only reason that Grindelwald
was defeated by Dumbledore while
wielding this wand is because Dumbledore
is such an immensely powerful wizard the
one is 15 inches long and made of alder
wood with carvings that resemble
clusters of elderberries running down
its length it notably contains a
threshold tail hair core it is said that
those wielding this wand are able to
perform feats of magic that would
otherwise be impossible one of these
feats is the ability to mend other wands
that would not normally be able to be
repaired through magic some believe that
if Dumbledore were to have wielded this
wand in the pursuit of evil he would
have been unstoppable and with that my
fellow witches and wizards that pretty
much concludes the list of the most
powerful wands in the Harry Potter
universe at least in this concise video
I'm sure there are many more but these
are the top five if you have any
questions or comments please post them
in the comment section down below and I
will see you all or actually we will see
you all in the next video of Harry
Potter theory